for more on president Trump's first
official foreign trip we're joined by
and Amanda Thao she writes for The New
York Times interpreter column Amanda
good morning hey good morning Amanda
let's start with the speech president
Trump is set to make tomorrow where he's
going to call for unity in the month of
Muslim world in terms of fighting
Islamic extremism this speech was
written we are told by Stephen Miller
the architect of the president's failed
Muslim ban what is your expectation of
that it is difficult to imagine what a
Stephen Miller authored speech in Saudi
Arabia might look like I think that the
possibility that they will try to play
to president Trump's domestic base at
home with some of the criticism of Islam
and simultaneously try to make an
outreach to a US ally in the speech
could lead to a lot of trouble it's a
very very difficult topic to get right
well what what is what is he dealing
with in terms of relations at this point
with Saudi Arabia I mean he said he said
in the past is Lama hates us if you're
going in with that comment what does he
have to do there do you think too - Ari
- to reform up relations so Saudi Arabia
is a US ally they have been for a long
time and I think that wouldn't change
because of something that was said on
the campaign trail but there is
certainly I think a lot of tension about
what might be said on this trip
particularly if President Trump goes off
speak off off script and if he says
anything like that I think that could
cause a great deal of trouble on this
trip and then there's this secondary
question of what will actually be in the
script for this speech and I think that
there are a lot of questions about that
particularly because Stephen Miller is
rumored to have written it let's look
forward to his visit to Israel how much
damages you have to do is there damage
being done given the fact that the
president appeared to have leaked
classified information that may have put
an Israeli asset in danger so I think
that is something that is likely to
cause a great deal of tension during
this trip both because you know people
within the Israeli security
establishment are going to have actual
questions that they want answered about
the security of information they might
share with the United States but also
because the backdrop of any trip like
this is for the President and senior
officials to be able to make a
connection and make promises and
agreements with foreign officials and
that calls into question whether the
United States keeps its promises or
whether President Trump might change his
mind at the drop of a hat
he's also expected to meet with the
Palestinian leader Mahmoud Abbas and
says he wants to broker a bigger and
better deal between the Palestinians and
the Israelis is he going to make any
headway here do you think I think that
it's unlikely you know a trip like this
certainly can move goals like that
forward face to face interaction matters
a great deal for this kind of thing and
so it's not out of the question that he
could make some progress but the fact
that President Trump has changed his
mind so frequently on important issues
and has shown himself to be fairly
malleable based on conversations with
foreign leaders on issues like NAFTA in
the past I think will make it difficult
for either the Israelis or the
Palestinians to know how much US policy
is set on this and how much they can set
store by whatever happens and
negotiations on this trip and then
dovetail thank you very much for being
with us this morning thank you